yeah oh yes yes I've broken in and now I
shall swing swung oh no I always wanted
a piercing down there
oops key miss me [ __ ] Oh what you think
you got me just cuz you pierced me by my
grundle
well eventually I'll get off of here or
I'll break my pelvis in half steer to
Diamond raid5 for secret wind
how about Cano oh how in the Frick
y-yeah ha ha that didn't work this was
really hard there we go hi she'll swing
swung yes mine jump oh god oh god where
am I going
I am flying Oh God
oh my god this one seems challenging oh
jeez jeez jeez ah [ __ ] hell
for me oh maybe if I jump maybe that'll
help okay
maybe if I keep jumping jump through the
obstacles
you don't like that song
oh geez man is calling me oh my eyes
live aerial harpoons I think you're just
using the names for their fortune oh my
god I figure just using the name slowed
their EO to get more clicks on a pole
well hello wormy am I still alive
somehow magically I've popped back into
shape let me not waste this opportunity
I'm so puffy oh I'm gonna get this
eventually I just gonna be less stupid
about it there's a bit of a challenge
I'm trying my best here but it's a Oh a
red ball oh well that's a speedy ball
that's a nice girthy ball I like the
tentacle penises on your balls
hello hi can you break yes SuperSpeed
jetpack job son don't talk to me when
I'm drinking dead Oh [ __ ] hell Jesus
oh oh my god I can't get over this hump
your hump is impenetrable Billy there we
go well I'm sure this will improve my
chances very much so
sorry I don't I don't know I don't know
how do you survive
thanks for slowing down the vehicle
Wow hey these aren't fire balls enough
sorry kid sorry sorry whoa yeah I'm too
flexible for you ah [ __ ] ow
I'm so sorry he was aiming for the
pieces where am i bleeding from oh okay
how about the Kamehameha oh well that
hurt for you but not a lot for me okay
that [ __ ] you son okay yeah epic oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] I wasn't ready hang on
well I've dunked myself I think that's
the only victory I really need well
freeze wall 3d yes sorry oh oh that's
cool
I mean it's blocked up my way already
but that's cool oh [ __ ] dude scoop it
out of the way that's the stuff that's
just my son well goodbye also forever
apparently that sweet embrace of death
though I can get over you I can't get
over you just like I got over my wife
cheating on me with the mailman I just
got sailed through it high speed high
velocity that's what this needs
[ __ ] haha what joke's on you I'm
resilient and Brazilian haha take 2000
she's dangerous keep your head cotton
ease well the pair
what happened survived not me okay it's
an affair [ __ ] man [ __ ] balls I'm like a
crazy ostrich wanna [ __ ] me this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye